This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the spring of 1992, the Baltimore Orioles opened their baseball season at a brand new stadium called Oriole Park at Camden Yards. It sat right along the harbor in downtown Baltimore. The Baltimore Orioles pulled out all of the stops for opening day at brand new Camden Yards. At over time, ballpark in the heart of downtown. The stadium was small, in intimate. It was built with brick and iron trusses, a throwback to the classic ball parks
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。1992 年春，巴尔的摩金莺队在一座名为金莺公园（Oriole Park at Camden Yards）的全新球场迎来了他们的棒球赛季。它就坐落在巴尔的摩市中心的港口边。巴尔的摩金莺队为这座全新金莺公园的揭幕战做足了准备。随着时间的推移，这座位于市中心的球场。这座球场小巧而温馨。它由红砖和铁桁架建造，是对早期经典棒球场的一种致敬
from the early 20th century. But on this day, it was the future, not the past, that was on the minds of Oriole fans, as they clocked the Camden Yards in what was the first of 67 Southuts, 59 of them in a row. Camden yards was really popular right from the start. Here's a TV reporter interviewing a bunch of Orioles fans on opening day. Outstanding, outstanding day for baseball, outstanding park, and outstanding here for the Orioles. And credible! It's just unbelievable here! Beautiful! Baseball writers from around the country
来自20世纪初。但在这天，吸引金莺队球迷注意的不是过去，而是未来，当他们注意到卡姆登 Yards 在前 67 个 Southuts 中的第一个时，其中 59 个是连续的。卡姆登 Yards 从一开始就非常受欢迎。这里有一位电视记者在揭幕战中采访了一群金莺队的球迷。出色的，棒球运动出色的日子，出色的公园，以及金莺队的出色表现。难以置信！这里简直难以置信！太美了！来自全国各地的棒球作家
keep praise on the Orioles new park. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. Tim Kirchen wrote in Sports Illustrated, it's magnificent, and an understated baseball only real grass open air, quirky, cozy, comfortable, cool sort of a way. All the national attention took the team by surprise. We were just out to build a ballpark that worked for Baltimore, this blue collar city, home of crab cakes, netty bow and boogs, barbecues.
对金莺队的新球场赞不绝口。那是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）。蒂姆·柯臣（Tim Kurkjian）在《体育画报》上写道，它宏伟壮观，低调而纯粹是棒球专属的、真正的天然草皮、露天、古朴、温馨、舒适、酷炫的一种方式。所有的全国关注让球队始料未及。我们只是想建造一个适合巴尔的摩这座蓝领城市的球场，这里是蟹饼、National Bohemian啤酒和Boog's烤肉的发源地。
This is Janet Marie Smith, one of the designers of Camden Yards. You know, we weren't looking to create something that would change the paradigm of baseball parks. But that's exactly what happened. The success of Camden Yards set off a building boom in baseball, as city after city built new stadiums based on the architectural principles laid down in Baltimore. That design revolution changed the experience of going to the ballpark and the relationship between baseball and cities. But to understand what made Camden Yards feel so special in 1992, we need a little bit of history.
这是珍妮特·玛丽·史密斯（Janet Marie Smith），金莺公园的设计者之一。你知道的，我们并不是在寻找创造能改变棒球场范式的东西。但事实恰恰如此。金莺公园的成功在棒球界引发了一场建设热潮，一个又一个城市根据巴尔的摩奠定的建筑原则建造了新球场。这场设计革命改变了去球场看球的体验，也改变了棒球与城市之间的关系。但要理解为什么 1992 年的金莺公园会让人感觉如此特别，我们需要了解一点历史。
In the early 1900s, most baseball stadiums were relatively small and built in dense urban neighborhoods. But in the 1950s and 60s, as white populations fled downtown for the suburbs, baseball followed them. Teams built stadiums on the edge of cities where they would be more accessible to middle-class fans who drove to games in cars. They often were acres and acres of parking surrounding the stadium. And the stadiums themselves were these massive concrete cylinders designed to house more than one sport. From Pittsburgh to Atlanta to Milwaukee, everyone had this big round hulking, concrete stadium that generally housed both baseball and football. But these multipurpose stadiums, or concrete donuts, as they were sometimes called, really
在 20 世纪初，大多数棒球场相对较小，建在密集的城市街区中。但在 20 世纪 50 和 60 年代，随着白人人口从市中心逃往郊区，棒球也随之而去。球队将球场建在城市边缘，这样驾车去球场的的中产阶级球迷更容易到达。球场周围通常有数英亩的停车场。而球场本身则是这些巨大的混凝土圆柱体，旨在容纳多项运动。从匹兹堡到亚特兰大再到密尔沃基，每个人都有这种又大又笨重的混凝土球场，通常既容纳棒球又容纳美式橄榄球。但这些多功能体育场，有时被称为混凝土甜甜圈，其实
weren't great for fans of either sport. The sort of joke was they became multipurpose less. They were perfectly round to fit both a football field and a baseball diamond, but that meant that the seats were often really far away from the action or angled in weird directions. So it ended up being a shape that accommodated everything but served nothing well. And the multi-purpose stadiums were just way too big for baseball. The old urban ball parks had about 25 or 30,000 seats, but these had 50,000 or more. It just didn't work, you know, except for a playoff game, you simply weren't selling
对任何一项运动的球迷来说都不是很好。当时的笑话是它们变成了多功能不足。它们是完美的圆形，既能容纳橄榄球场又能容纳棒球场，但这意味着座位往往离比赛区域非常远，或者角度很诡异。所以它最终变成了一种能容纳一切却什么也做不好的形状。而且这些多功能体育场对棒球来说实在太大了。老式的城市棒球场大约有 25,000 到 30,000 个座位，而这些则有 50,000 个或更多。这根本行不通，你知道的，除了季后赛，你根本卖不出
that many tickets. So the stadiums often felt empty, and critics also complained that they all looked exactly the same. They were not distinctive enough. You didn't know if you were in three rivers, stadiums, or you were in 3 rivers, stadium, or you were in Riverfront Stadium, or you were in Veteran Stadium, you really didn't know what city you were in or could be in. This is Larry Lucchino. He was the president of the Orioles in the late 80s and early 90s.
那么多门票。因此，球场常常显得空空荡荡，批评者还抱怨它们看起来完全一样。它们没有足够的独特性。你根本不知道自己是在三河体育场（Three Rivers Stadium），还是在河滨体育场（Riverfront Stadium），亦或是老兵体育场（Veterans Stadium），你真的不知道自己身处哪座城市，或者可能会在哪座城市。这是拉里·卢基诺（Larry Lucchino）。他是 80 年代末和 90 年代初金莺队的总裁。
And during that time, the Orioles played in their own concrete donut, Memorial Stadium, which had once housed Baltimore's football team, the Colts. But in 1984, the Colts abandoned the city for Indianapolis. A long, agonizing, frustrating two and a half months of waiting and wondering if the Baltimore Colts would be leaving town for good. It has happened. The shock is setting in. Emotions are running. And the Colts cited the inadequacy of aging memorial stadium as a reason for leaving. So there was a concern that unless something creative was done
在那段时间里，金莺队在他们自己的混凝土甜甜圈——纪念体育场（Memorial Stadium）里打球，这里曾是巴尔的摩橄榄球队小马队（Colts）的主场。但在 1984 年，小马队抛弃了这座城市，搬到了印第安纳波利斯。漫长、痛苦、令人沮丧的两个半月等待和猜测，巴尔的摩小马队是否会永远离开这座城市。事情已经发生了。震惊正在蔓延。情绪正在高涨。小马队以老化的纪念体育场不敷使用为由选择离开。因此人们担心，除非在巴尔的摩为金莺队做点有创意的事
in Baltimore for the orios, that we might follow the example of the cults and leave town for greener ball parks, if you will. The team's owner, Edward Bennett Williams, wanted to build a nice new multi-purpose stadium so that the city could try and court another football team back to Baltimore. But Larry Lucino had a different idea. He went to Edward Williams and said to him, let's look at the most successful baseball franchises out there.
我们可能会步小马队的后尘，离开这座城市去寻找更美好的球场，如果你愿意这么说的话。球队老板爱德华·班尼特·威廉姆斯（Edward Bennett Williams）想要建造一座漂亮的新多功能体育场，以便这座城市能够尝试将另一支橄榄球队吸引回巴尔的摩。但拉里·卢基诺有不同的想法。他去找爱德华·威廉姆斯对他说，让我们看看现今最成功的棒球特许经营权。
The Yankees and Yankees stadium, the Cubs in Wrigley Field, the Red Sox in Fenway Park, and what did they have in common? They all played in a baseball-only facility, a facility that was designed for baseball, and it did not compromise architecturally for other sports. Those stadiums actually had another thing in common. They were really old. Some of the last holdouts from the pre-war era of urban ballpark baseball.
洋基队和洋基体育场（Yankee Stadium），小熊队的瑞格利球场（Wrigley Field），红袜队的芬威球场（Fenway Park），它们有什么共同点？它们都在纯棒球场设施中比赛，一个专为棒球设计的设施，并且在建筑上没有为其他运动做妥协。这些球场其实还有另一个共同点。它们真的很老。是战前城市棒球场时代的最后几块保留地。
And unlike the concrete donuts, the ballpark's built back then had all these architectural quirks, Fenway's green monster, or Rigglyfield's iconic brick walls covered in ivy. They were all a little bit of a different flavor of ice cream. We thought that something was lost when baseball moved from those kinds of facilities to generic multipurpose stadiums in the 60s and 70s.
与混凝土甜甜圈不同，当年建造的球场有各种各样的建筑怪癖，比如芬威的绿色怪物（Green Monster），或者瑞格利球场爬满常春藤的标志性红砖墙。它们都带有不同风味的冰淇淋。我们认为，当棒球在 60 和 70 年代从那种设施搬到通用的多功能体育场时，有些东西丢失了。
Duquino wanted to break out of the multipurpose paradigm and build a new kind of baseball-only stadium, one that felt old. An old fashioned traditional baseball park with modern amenities if we use that phrase once we used it to 10,000 times. In fact, Lucchino became so zealous in his commitment to building an old fashioned ballpark that he banned Orioles employees from even using the word stadium. Indeed, we find people five dollars
卢基诺想要打破多功能范式，建造一种新型的纯棒球场，一种感觉古老的球场。一座融合了现代便利设施的老式传统棒球场——如果我们用过这个词一次，那就是用了有一万次了。事实上，卢基诺对建造一座老式棒球场的执着达到了狂热的程度，他甚至禁止金莺队员工使用“体育场”（stadium）这个词。确切地说，我们会罚款五美元
if they use the S-word stadium instead of referring to our project as a ballpark. A stadium canode something very different in terms of size and monumentality. Did you ever collect on those fines? Yeah, we did collect. We had a little party. I don't remember how much we got, but it wasn't in substantial. The Orioles struck a deal with the Maryland S-word Authority to build a new baseball only ballpark in Baltimore, using mostly public money.
如果他们使用了“S”开头的词“体育场”，而不是将我们的项目称为“球场”（ballpark）。在规模和纪念性方面，“stadium”可以传达非常不同的东西。你真的收过那些罚款吗？是的，我们确实收了。我们举办了一个小型派对。我不记得我们收了多少钱，但绝对不是一笔小数目。金莺队与马里兰州 S 字头管理局（Maryland Stadium Authority）达成协议，主要使用公共资金在巴尔的摩建造一座新的纯棒球场。
The city and state government saw it as part of an effort to revitalize downtown. The stadium authority hired the architecture firm H.O.K. and the Orioles brought in their own design director Janet Marie Smith. My assignment was really to take those words that he used over and over again of an old-fashioned ballpark with modern amenities and try and make certain that we were really being true to that. It wasn't an easy task. No one else had moved into a center city and said,
市和州政府将其视为重振市中心工作的一部分。体育场管理局聘请了建筑事务所 H.O.K.，金莺队则引入了他们自己的设计总监珍妮特·玛丽·史密斯。我的任务其实就是把那些他反复使用的词——带有现代便利设施的老式球场——落到实处，并确保我们真正忠于这一点。这并非易事。没有其他人搬到市中心中心并说过，
we want to be a part of that tapestry. And Golly, maybe 70 years. How are we going to create something that feels like it's woven into the city of Baltimore? And like it's always belonged here. Janet Marie Smith turned to the ball parks from the early 1900s for inspiration. What made those older ball park special is that they were kind of
我们想成为那块织锦的一部分。天哪，也许有70年了。我们要如何创造出一种感觉像是融入了巴尔的摩这座城市的东西？就像它一直属于这里一样。珍妮特·玛丽·史密斯将目光转向了 20 世纪初的球场以寻找灵感。那些老球场的特别之处在于它们被
wedged into a very tight urban environment. And by wedged, she means that the urban environment actually dictated the shape of the field. Each ball park had different dimensions, depending on the plot of land on which it was built. Which can only really happen in baseball. with most sports, the dimensions of the playing field are totally standardized, but not baseball. Their rules about the infield, they've got to be, you know, you've got to have 90 feet between the bases, 60 feet, six inches from home plate to the pictures mound, but there's no rule about the outfield.
挤在非常狭窄的城市环境中。她所说的“挤”，是指城市环境实际上决定了球场的形状。每个球场都有不同的尺寸，这取决于建造它的土地地块。这在棒球运动中才能真正发生。对于大多数运动来说，比赛场地的尺寸是完全标准化的，但棒球不是。关于内野的规则是，你必须，你知道的，垒包之间必须有 90 英尺，本垒到投手丘必须有 60 英尺 6 英寸，但对外野没有任何规定。
And so a lot of the early American ball parks were totally asymmetrical. Ebets Field, built in a Brooklyn neighborhood called Pigtown, had a wildly irregular shape. The left field foul pole was over 50 feet further from home plate than the right field foul pole. That variety means that some ball parks are better for pictures, others are better for hitters, some ball parks give up more home runs to right handed batters, others to lefties. So the the park itself really does shape the outcome of the game. Larry Lucchino wanted an irregular playing field like those old time ball parks, but he felt that the shape needed to respond to the built environment around the site. To make sure that this ballpark was integrated into its neighborhood,
因此，早期的大多数美国球场都是完全不对称的。埃贝茨球场（Ebbets Field）建在布鲁克林一个叫猪镇（Pigtown）的街区，有着极其不规则的形状。左外野界桩比右外野界桩距离本垒远了 50 多英尺。这种多样性意味着一些球场对投手更好，另一些对击球手更好，有些球场让右打者打出更多本垒打，另一些则对左打者有利。所以球场本身确实塑造了比赛的结果。拉里·卢基诺想要一个像那些老式球场那样不规则的比赛场地，但他觉得这个形状需要回应场地周围的建筑环境。为了确保这座球场融入其所在的街区，
it didn't feel like I'm flying saucer that descended and just landed in the neighborhood. The inner harbor site where Camden Yards would be built had one distinct architectural feature, the B&O warehouse, an extremely long brick building built at the turn of the 20th century. It was abandoned at the time, and a lot of people thought that the Orioles should just tear it down to give themselves more room to build on and to open up a view to the water. One sports editor wrote that it was an empty, rat-infested fire trap, and it should be done away with.
它感觉不像是一个降落在街区里的飞碟。卡姆登 Yards 建造所在的内港（Inner Harbor）地块有一个独特的建筑特色，即 B&O 仓库（B&O Warehouse），这是一座建于 20 世纪之交的极长的红砖建筑。当时它已被废弃，许多人认为金莺队应该把它直接拆掉，以便为自己腾出更多建设空间，并开阔通往水面的视野。一位体育编辑写道，它是一个空置的、鼠患成灾的火灾隐患，应该被彻底铲除。
But Janet Marie Smith didn't want to do that. We felt strongly that tearing down the very contexts that might give form to an asymmetrical playing field and asymmetrical seating bowl was running against the grain of what Larry wanted. So they left the warehouse, which would eventually sit just beyond right field and design the shape of the playing field around it. In fact, Lucino says that the decision to preserve the warehouse really dictated nearly every other design decision that went into Camden Yards. From the shape of the stands down to the materials that they used in construction.
但珍妮特·玛丽·史密斯不想这么做。我们坚信，拆除那些可能赋予不对称比赛场地和不对称观众席形态的背景，是违背拉里意愿的。因此，他们保留了这座仓库，它最终将坐落在右外野后方，并围绕它设计了比赛场地的形状。事实上，卢基诺表示，保留仓库的决定确实决定了几乎所有进入金莺公园的其他设计决定。从看台的形状到他们在建设中使用的材料。
It gave us the sort of brick motif that we used in the ballpark and it gave us the iconic symbol of this ballpark for Baltimore and it looked a lot like Baltimore and felt a lot like Baltimore. If you go to Camden Yards today, it's almost hard to tell where the stadium ends and the warehouse begins. Larry Lukino and Janet Marie Smith were both at Camden Yards on opening day. I can tell you that we were all anxious, you know, hair standing on our back. Like, what if it, you know, what if it didn't work?
它给了我们我们在球场中使用的那种红砖母题，它给了我们这座球场对巴尔的摩的标志性象征，它看起来很像巴尔的摩，也很有巴尔的摩的感觉。如果你今天去金莺公园，几乎很难分清哪里是体育场结束，哪里是仓库开始。拉里·卢基诺和珍妮特·玛丽·史密斯在揭幕战当天都在金莺公园。我可以告诉你，我们当时都很焦虑，你知道的，汗毛都竖起来了。比如，万一它，你知道的，万一它不管用呢？
I mean, there were any number of things that ran counter to the norm in sports stadium design that could have gone wrong and any number of things that were normal that could have just gone wrong. You know, the toilet's not flushing. I don't know. Pick anything. But nothing went wrong. The ticket sold out. The toilets flushed just fine. And the Orioles did their job on the field. So, rental chains are very quick, and the Orioles are in the ring column opening day. Janet and I found each other just as the game ended and embraced each other. And I think she said, it plays, it plays. There was a big headline across the front page of the Baltimore Sun, the day after opening
我的意思是，有任意数量违背体育场设计常规的事情可能会出错，也有任意数量正常的事情可能会出岔子。你知道的，马桶冲不下水。我不知道。随便挑一个吧。但什么都没出错。门票卖光了。马桶冲水也很正常。金莺队在场上也做好了他们的工作。所以，租賃连锁反应非常快，金莺队在揭幕战的赢球栏里。珍妮特和我刚一比赛结束就找到了彼此，拥抱在了一起。我想她说，这行得通，这行得通。巴尔的摩太阳报（Baltimore Sun）头版在揭幕战次日醒目地印着一个大标题
day that said, it's a hit. You know, a big two and a half inch letters as if we'd won the election or something. All that year, people kept coming out to the ballpark in droves. When we opened in 1992, the attendance went from something like 2.2 or 2.3 million to 3.6 million. In the second year was 3.7 million. In their first two seasons at Camden Yards, the Orioles had the second highest attendance in the major leagues. And pretty soon, other teams started to take notice. Owners from Texas and from Cleveland and Colorado came to visit us rather extensively.
上面写着，这是一次轰动。你知道的，两英寸半的大字，就好像我们赢得了一整场选举或者别的什么。整整一年，人们成群结队地涌向球场。当我们于 1992 年开业时，上座人数从大约 220 万或 230 万飙升至 360 万。第二年则是 370 万。在金莺公园的前两个赛季，金莺队的上座率位居大联盟第二。很快，其他球队开始注意到这一点。来自德克萨斯、克利夫兰和科罗拉多（Colorado）的老板们广泛地前来拜访我们。
Then in 1994, another old-fashioned baseball only ballpark called Jacob's Field opened in downtown Cleveland, and that was just the beginning. It became impossible to build a new ballpark and not have it look like an old ballpark. That's Mark Lampster, architecture critic at the Dallas Morning News, and a fellow at the Harvard Graduate School of Design. And that way I'd like to joke that baseball owners were a bit like teenagers.
然后在 1994 年，另一座名为雅各布斯球场（Jacob's Field）的复古纯棒球场在克利夫兰市中心开业，而这仅仅是个开始。建造一座新球场却不让它看起来像个老球场，这变得不可能了。这是马克·兰普斯特（Mark Lamster），《达拉斯晨报》（Dallas Morning News）的建筑评论员，也是哈佛大学设计研究生院的研究员。我喜欢开玩笑说，棒球老板们在某种程度上就像青少年。
What the first cool one does, then all of a sudden, everybody else does. So if one person has a retro ballpark and it's successful then the conventional wisdom becomes in order to be successful you have to have a retro ballpark. In the 25 years since Camden opened there have been 20 new stadiums built and there's not a concrete donut in the bunch. And just like Camden Yards, most of these new stadiums have been built close to city centers, and all but one of them have been paid for, at least in part, with public money.
第一个酷的人做了什么，突然之间，其他人都会跟着做。所以，如果一个人拥有一个复古球场并且很成功，那么传统观点就会变成：要想成功，你也必须拥有一个复古球场。在卡姆登开业以来的 25 年里，已经建造了 20 座新球场，其中没有一个是什么混凝土甜甜圈。就像金莺公园一样，这些新球场大多建在靠近市中心的地方，而且除了其中一座之外，其余所有球场至少有一部分是用公共资金支付的。
Camden Yards really hit upon the formula, right? This is Neil Demas, a journalist who studies stadium economics. Here's something that's supposedly a win-win-win, right? It's a win for the team because they get new revenue, it's a win for the fans because they get a stadium that they love, and it's a win for the team because they get new revenue. It's a win for the fans because they get a stadium that they love. And it's a win for the city because they get to revitalize a district. But most economists agree that if you want to revitalize a neighborhood, there are plenty of better ways than building a ballpark.
金莺公园确实找到了秘诀，对吧？这是尼尔·德马斯（Neil Demas），一位研究体育场经济学的记者。这里有一些被认为是双赢赢的事，对吧？这对球队来说是双赢，因为他们获得了新的收入；对球迷来说是双赢，因为他们得到了一个他们热爱的体育场；对球队来说是双赢，因为他们获得了新的收入。这对球迷来说是双赢，因为他们得到了他们热爱的体育场。这对城市来说是双赢，因为他们得以重振一个街区。但大多数经济学家都认为，如果你想重振一个街区，比起建造一座球场，有的是更好的方法。
Demas says that when a new stadium gets built, you'll see some sports bars pop up nearby. But most businesses can't rely on baseball crowds as a customer base. You know, the 81 games a year, that means there's what, like, you know, 280 days a year when there's nothing going on there. That's an awful lot of non-activity that you have to make up for. There's also the more fundamental question of whether the public should have to pay for privately owned buildings. Mark Lampster says it's tricky. Sports teams occupy
德马斯表示，当一座新体育场建成时，你会看到一些运动酒吧在附近涌现。但大多数企业无法将棒球观众作为主要的客户群。你知道的，一年 81 场比赛，这意味着什么，比如，你知道的，一年中有 280 天左右那里什么都没有发生。为了弥补这一点，你必须应付大量的闲置时间。还有一个更根本的问题，即公众是否应该为私有建筑付费。马克·兰普斯特说这很棘手。体育运动占据了
this strange space. They're both businesses and public amenities. Sports are really important for cities. They help create an identity. People love them. They bring cities together. So there is some justification for cities supporting even a privately owned team. But Lancaster says most cities have much more urgent spending needs than a new baseball stadium, like education. And it's hard to say what level of taxpayer contribution is fair. Especially when it's going straight into the pocket of very, very, very wealthy individuals.
这个奇怪的空间。它们既是商业企业，又是公共设施。体育对城市真的很重要。它们有助于塑造身份认同。人们热爱它们。它们将城市凝聚在一起。因此，城市支持哪怕是私有球队也有一定的正当性。但兰普斯特表示，相比于一座新的棒球场，大多数城市有着更为紧迫的支出需求，比如教育。而且很难说纳税人的出资比例达到多少才算公平。特别是当这些钱直接进入了非常、非常、非常富有的人的口袋里时。
But these difficult questions haven't stopped the retro ballpark building boom. Across the country, baseball teams have done everything they can to follow the Camden template, right down to hiring the same architecture firm, HOK Sport, which has since spun off into its own independent firm called Populous. It's almost a law that the new ballpark is by Populous.
但这些棘手的问题并没有阻止复古球场建设热潮。在全国各地，棒球球队竭尽所能地效仿卡姆登的模版，甚至不惜雇佣同一家建筑事务所——HOK Sport（后更名为独立公司 Populous）。新球场由 Populous 设计几乎成了一种规律。
And like Camden, most of the new Populous stadiums are small, baseball-only ballparks, with comfortable seats and fancy food options. And aesthetically, they're designed to look like the ballparks from the early 1900s. The palette of Camden Yard has become a cliche of ballpark design. That is, the brick, the green-painted iron, the green seats, the typography. It is all of a piece and it became widely adopted all across the country. Each of these new parks had an asymmetrical playing field. And like with Baltimore, their dimensions were often determined by the surrounding city
就像卡姆登一样，大部分由 Populous 设计的新球场都是小型的、纯棒球场，配有舒适的座位和高档的餐饮选择。在美学上，它们的精髓在于看起来像 20 世纪初的球场。金莺公园的色彩和元素已经成了球场设计的陈词滥调。也就是说，红砖、绿漆铁艺、绿色座椅、字体排印。这一切浑然一体，并在全国范围内被广泛采用。这些新球场每一个都有一个不对称的比赛场地。就像巴尔的摩一样，它们的尺寸通常由周围的城市
escape. In San Diego's Petco Park, the historic Western Metal Supply Company building dictates the length of the left field line. Instead of building a foul pole, the team just painted a yellow stripe down the corner of the warehouse. AT&T Park in San Francisco is squeezed right up against the San Francisco Bay. The right field line goes all the way to the water, giving fans a spectacular view, and creating a unique local drama, splash down home runs. When someone hits a ball into the bay, a flotilla of kayakers descend on the souvenir. But not all the new retro ball parks were so successfully integrated with
景观决定。在圣迭戈的沛可公园（Petco Park），历史悠久的西方金属供应公司（Western Metal Supply Company）大楼决定了左外野边界的长度。球队没有修建界桩，而是在仓库的墙角直接刷上了一条黄线。旧金山的 AT&T 球场紧贴着旧金山湾。右外野边界一直延伸到水边，为球迷提供了壮观的视野，并创造了一个独特的本地戏剧性事件——场外本垒打（splash-down home runs）。当有人把球击入海湾时，一群皮划艇爱好者便会蜂拥而上抢夺纪念品。但并非所有的新复古球场都成功地与
the urban landscape. Take city field, the new Met Stadium in Queens. It has an asymmetrical shape, but not because it's wedged into a tight urban lot. It's actually set out in the same place that its predecessor, Shay Stadium, was in the middle of a parking lot, and it has all these idiosyncratic dimensions, but there's really no reason for its idiosyncrasy is not driven by any particular constraint of the area around it. It's entirely artificial.
城市景观融为一体。以花旗球场（Citi Field）为例，这是皇后区大都会队（Met Stadium）的新球场。它拥有不对称的形状，但不是因为它被挤在一个狭窄的城市地块里。它实际上建在与其前身谢Shea体育场（Shea Stadium）完全相同的地方——一个停车场中央，它拥有所有这些怪异的尺寸，但它的怪异其实毫无理由，也并非由其周围地区的任何特定限制所驱动。它是完全人造的。
When you're at city field, Mark Lampster says you can feel how hard the architects worked to manufacture a sense of history and authenticity. He says that everyone in the league has been so focused on building these old-fashioned idiosyncratic ball parks like Camden that they've actually created a new architectural orthodoxy. They all have exactly the same DNA, They're all designed by the same firm. They all kind of look the same,
当你在花旗球场时，马克·兰普斯特说，你能感受到建筑师为了人为营造出一种历史感和真实感付出了多大的努力。他说，联盟里的每个人都太专注于建造像卡姆登那样老式的、古怪的球场，以至于他们实际上创造了一种新的建筑正统。它们都拥有完全相同的 DNA，它们都由同一家公司设计。它们看起来都差不多，
except the whole idea is that each one is idiosyncratic and individual. It's a tall tale. Despite his critiques, Mark Lampster says there's no denying that the post-Camden ball parks are better places to watch baseball than the old concrete behemoths.
除了整个理念是每一个都古怪且独特。这是一个离奇的故事。尽管有这些批评，马克·兰普斯特表示，不可否认的是，卡姆登之后的球场比老旧的混凝土庞然大物更适合观看棒球比赛。
Even cityfield in New York, the stadium lamps to a cues of trying a little too hard, is still way nicer than its predecessor, Shay Stadium. Can you describe Shay Stadium? Can I describe Shay Stadium? Yes, I can describe Shay Stadium. Think of a toilet. Put seats in it. That's Shay Stadium. Was it a toilet. Put seats in it. That's Shay Stadium.
即使是纽约的花旗球场，那个被兰普斯特指责有点用力过猛的体育场，也依然比它的前身谢伊体育场要好得多。你能描述一下谢伊体育场吗？我能描述谢伊体育场吗？是的，我可以描述谢伊体育场。想想马桶。在里面放上座位。那就是谢伊体育场。那是个马桶。在里面放上座位。那就是谢伊体育场。
Was it a nice place to watch a game? No. Is the new place a nice place to watch the game? Absolutely. It's a much, much nicer place to watch a game. It's a really great place to watch a game. And being a nice place to watch a game is important for baseball.
那是个看比赛的好地方吗？不是。新地方是个看比赛的好地方吗？绝对是的。那是一个好得多、好得多的看比赛的地方。那真的是一个看比赛的好地方。而成为一个看比赛的好地方对棒球运动来说至关重要。
In recent decades, sports, television ratings have started to slide, but attendance numbers are strong. And these ball parks are part of the reason why, because they're fun places to go. People enjoy sitting there watching a game. And for me, enjoying the game has always had a bit of nostalgia to it. I don't even follow baseball that closely, but I'll go eat a hot dog and listen to the Yorgon music because it feels like a fun tradition. More than any other sport, baseball is about its own past and plays to its nostalgic history.
近几十年来，体育电视收视率开始下滑，但上座率数据却很强劲。这些球场就是原因之一，因为它们是去起来很有趣的地方。人们喜欢坐在那里看比赛。对我而言，享受比赛一直带有一点怀旧情绪。我甚至不是那么密切关注棒球，但我会去吃个热狗，听听管风琴音乐，因为这感觉像是一个有趣的传统。与其他任何体育运动相比，棒球更关乎它自己的过去，并且迎合了其怀旧的历史。
That obsession with history drove the retro ballpark revolution, but as an architecture critic, Mark LAMSTER is ready for some team out there to embrace the future. Why were we looking back and nostalgicly when we designed these ball parks instead of looking towards new materials and new ways of building and new architecture? And if Camden Yards has taught us anything, it's that when someone does come up with a great new way of building a ballpark, every team in the league is going to want one of their own. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald with tech production and mixed mixed by Sir Refuse of, and music by Sean Riel.
这种对历史的痴迷推动了复古球场革命，但作为一名建筑评论员，马克·兰普斯特已经准备好迎接某个团队去拥抱未来了。为什么我们在设计这些球场时要回顾过去并充满怀旧情绪，而不是着眼于新材料、新的建造方式和新建筑呢？如果说金莺公园教会了我们什么，那就是当有人想出一种建造球场的新绝妙方法时，联盟里的每一支球队都会想要属于他们自己的一个。99% Invisible 本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，技术制作和混音由 Sir Refuse of 负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Rial）创作。
Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director and Terran Mazza is moving down south to be my chief of staff. The rest of the team is Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffleman, and me, Roman Mars. If you haven't heard, I created a new podcast called What Trump Can Teach Us About Conlaw. It's a really fun and positive reaction to all the crazy political news I released it on the feed last week. I hope that you heard it. I hope you liked it.
凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监，泰兰·马扎（Terran Mazza）将南下担任我的办公厅主任。团队的其他成员包括德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、艾弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。如果你还没听说过，我创建了一个新播客，叫做《特朗普能教我们关于宪法的事》（What Trump Can Teach Us About Conlaw）。这是对我上周在动态中发布的所有疯狂政治新闻的一个非常有趣且积极的回应。我希望你听过了。我希望你喜欢它。
And I hope you subscribed. It is currently the number one podcast in the country on the Apple podcast chart. So thank you. You haven't heard yet. Check it out. I think you'll like it. In other side project news, our composer, Sean Rial,
我也希望你订阅了。它目前是 Apple 播客榜上全国排名第一的播客。所以谢谢你们。如果你还没听过。去看看吧。我想你会喜欢的。关于其他副业项目的新闻，我们的作曲家肖恩·里尔，
who's music you're listening to right now, has a new album called In the Theme Monster. The songs were recorded at different house shows and in his home studio, which is also where he produces all the music for 99PI. Stay tuned to the end of the show, but here a sample from the new album. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, supported by the Night Foundation and listeners, just like you.
你现在正在听的音乐就是他的作品，他有一张新专辑叫《情感怪兽》（The Emotion Monster）。这些歌曲是在不同的家庭演出和他的家庭工作室录制的，这也是他为 99PI 制作所有音乐的地方。请继续收听节目的结尾，这里有一段来自新专辑的采样。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的奥克兰市中心电台路（Radio Row）制作。我们是来自 PRX 的 RadioTopia 骄傲的创始成员，由奈特基金会（Knight Foundation）和像你这样的听众支持。
And now here's a sample from Sean Reale's the song, Simple Machine. Sheen's on time. Trouble sleeping, that's not news, but it always feels like the first time. Melodonin, it's amazing how much work it takes just to shut down the door And I'm gonna try replacing your drug with another Traffic's been long in my, there's nothing I can do but why now? Now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now, And it makes me stronger to know And it makes me proud when I deal But my brain still Oh, words me every time I smell your Tiny skin flakes blowing by
现在这里是肖恩·里尔的歌曲《简单机器》（Simple Machine）的采样。时间到了。睡眠困难，这不是新鲜事，但感觉总是像第一次。褪黑素，关上房门竟然需要付出这么多努力，这太神奇了。我要试着用另一种东西取代你的药。交通已经耽误了很久，我无能为力，但为什么是现在？现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在，现在飘过的小块皮屑。
Your tiny skin flakes blowing by Your tiny skin flakes blowing Empathy Monster by Sean Rial is available at www.SeanRial.bancamp.com on tape or digital download. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI or on Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too. But we play 156 home games a year at 99PI.org. Radio TMP from PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
飘过的小块皮屑 飘过的小块皮屑 肖恩·里尔的《情感怪兽》可在 www.SeanRial.bandcamp.com 购买磁带或数字下载。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，或在节目官方帐号 @99PI，或者在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但我们在 99PI.org 每年打 156 场主场比赛。来自 PRX 的 Radio Topia。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。